one person is dead tonight after a
stabbing in the central valley thank you
for joining us tonight at 11 o'clock i'm
sasha loftis this happened near
charleston and maryland parkway earlier
this evening and it's the second
homicide we've seen in just a few hours
madison kimbrough joins us live from the
scene now with the latest madison
a man was found lying in the road here
on charleston boulevard right near this
bus stop that you see behind me you can
take a look after further investigation
the victim described as a black man
around 30 years of age was found
suffering from a stab wound he was taken
to the hospital where he later died
according to metro a group of men had
been involved in an altercation on 11th
street that's just a block away north of
charleston during that altercation one
of the men stabbed the victim the victim
then ran away and that is where he
collapsed here on charleston boulevard
neighbors say lately the amount of crime
happening on their block is worrisome i
think it's a shame it does concern me
because it is so close but
again it's quiet in my area for the most
part
metro is still trying to identify the
other men involved including the suspect
we were told that the men ran from the
scene but still no idea on the
connection between the victim and the
suspect now what you're looking at right
now is the westbound lane that you see
on charleston it's been closed for hours
and as of now if you know anything about
this incident you are urged to contact
metro or crime stoppers to remain
anonymous reporting live madison
kimbrough 8 news now